[Music]
we're all here from the open sentence
community I work at Google Circus from
Microsoft and Steve is from stealth mode
sort of call dognition
we also have a few people in the
audience so we've some members of the
open census team here most notably
Bogdan Drew who's the team mascot and
he's sitting over there
we'll bring people up for questions at
the end so I'm guessing that most of you
already know what open census is for
those who don't open census is a set of
instrumentation libraries a little bit
more than that but its core the product
is a the project is a set of libraries
these libraries allow you to extract
distributed traces and metrics from your
applications they take care of things
like context propagation tag propagation
and basically all the things you need to
do to get observability with distributed
traces and metrics out of your ass
open census is somewhat unique in the
market it's not just an API it's an
actual full implementation so we
maintain a single distribution of these
libraries there's one for Java there's
one for no there's one for C++ and so on
so that we can ensure all of the
functionality that you expect a need is
there one of the really interesting
parts about open census is how you get
the data to your back-end so as I
mentioned it's just a set of libraries
we don't do distributed trace analytics
we don't do metrics analytics like
projects like Prometheus or Yaeger we
simply allow you to capture those
because that's a very difficult problem
so we have this concept in open sense
it's called exporters exporters are the
way that you send the data from your
application with open census to the your
back-end of choice so it's the way you
collect traces it's the way you pass on
traces to something like Yaeger it's the
way you pass on metrics it's just
something like Prometheus so if we have
a sample micro-services app in this case
we'd be we have the you know front-end
service payment service card service and
we're calling a database API in this
case we have open census linked inside
of our code for each of these services
it provides the API as we need and it
has the instrumentation that will in
most cases automatically capture traces
do context propagation capture critical
metrics and by linking it their traces
will be will capture traces from these
request flows that go through our
service and then we'll send this data to
our backends via these
order an interface that I mentioned
earlier one of the interesting things
about exporters is that you can export
to multiple backends at once this means
you can export to a tracing back-end
under metrics backend it also means that
you can export to multiple tracing and
metrics back ends at the same time this
is useful if you're evaluating a new
vendor or open-source project that
you're using its back-end it's also
useful if you have different teams who
are using different tools you can still
get that full stack observability with
like Jaeger and stack driver for example
or Prometheus and stack driver for
example with that I'm going to hand it
over to Sergey I'll see you back for a
second
you can count how many languages this
distributor top has and like for and
it's became in reality and the built
open census SDK for all these languages
is a tricky task so open census with
open sense we're doing that and I'm
happy to tell that for four languages
Java go lank not GSM Python will
announce production readiness this month
for all other languages it's coming
shortly after that so what does it mean
to build open sensors for a single
language you want to feel we're going to
make sure that it feels natural for you
to cut this open sensors on your
language the same time you want to
preserve all the terminology and also
look and feel of open sentences decay
across all the languages so it's easy
for you to switch back and forth we also
strive for standardization across
languages so let's say you distributed
trace goes from one component to another
component you shouldn't know that like
one component is Golin can add a
component net you just know that it will
be correlated automatically so you see
telemetry from both components and it
will be like magic magically linked
together we also strive to standardize
data we collect from all these languages
I mean it's not a it became an
increasingly important for you to do to
know that you can go and look at Chile
I'm from application code of the or
which you don't know because it may be
like your GP online service or service
you depend on and you are DRI and in the
middle
overnight and you need to look at
telemetry from for your sister team
application and we strive for
standardization I mean the
standardization is basically you you
shouldn't worry about accession alert on
response code for HTTP for the
application language you don't know is
the response code for HTTP you shouldn't
care we we work on this API
stabilization and testing for many
languages and one thing I want to talk
about is integrations this open sentence
is the key we want to make sure that it
can express your application pattern
whatever you use in your application
like it may be simple rest call or it
may be fancy tasks synchronization with
radius and database calls and in to
synchronize it all together oh it may be
some highly efficient queue based RPC
protocol between your component and this
open send is you want to make sure you
can express all that in a simple manner
and to enable that and to make sure that
we can do all these integrations we
created automatic data collections for
our technologies I could Java for
instance we do support HTTP GT RPC gdb
seen one KGB jetsetter less with the
embolization of API sand-like
announcement of some production rate if
you expect way more integrations and
integration is easier to enable like
single gesture way to enable monitoring
can data collection from those
components so what's missing on other
languages and in its big check boxes and
so on open census dot IO we track
detailed map of all the features and
capabilities of every single language so
you can go check it out there here I
show bird's eye view on what's enabled
and what's supported you can see that
metrics API is lagging behind and it's
not a surprise because metric CPI was
just introduced recently we working on
that with open metric CN CF project and
it just was introduced recently and we
already have integration for four
languages and if you've been on Morgan's
presentation from last year I want to
emphasize how much progress you made
over a year
I mean this mattress was no way near
that and we made the commitment to make
four languages up to parity like four
also main features and they achieve that
so you see like all the checkboxes on
four columns add as their so while we
were working on future party on all
other languages and treat it as a high
priority we also hear feedback that you
need more signals for observability and
one of the biggest feedback is you need
to log in so we start working on logging
as well locks is very important
observability signal you need logs to
troubleshoot and it logs are very easy
to write easy to collect easy to consume
unless it's not and it's not because
your application tend to became more
complex high scale and consists of too
many companies that written by different
vendors and it's all affect how you log
visa scale comes a cost
it became screens increasingly costly to
enable log so you turn them off with
complex business logic you have hard
time to navigate locks and make sense of
likewise this lock nut message comes
after that lock message it doesn't make
sense and with increased number of
components that you consume all the logs
looked different so you have hard time
to create them and understand what's
going on so we have a plan to address
all these problems we will start with
correlation of Vox and today you already
have a correlation and tags for
distributed traces pretty soon you'll be
able to use the same correlation and
tagging to group and scope your logs
then we plan to address some promises
caused with a collector you will be able
to do scenarios like changing only
logger both locks for only distributed
traces that had errors in them and you
can do it with attractive sampling when
you now
cash all the informations and only send
subjective information that is most
important for you across all your
components distributed
across multiple languages then we want
to do a scenarios like a sampling based
on verbosity of your logs you may want
to collect only 20% of informational
logs and errors and warnings all the
time that kind of scenarios you want to
enable for you to address cost issues
and that can be done on open sense agent
or even directly in SDK and then lastly
we will maybe it's a longer term goal
but we want to provide better login KPI
so you can look consistently and
responsibly consistently means that I
mean our minbar is very low like we want
to make sure that computer name reported
by one system is a computer name report
by another system so you don't you can
create those two computer names what we
want our team Utley is to make sure that
we can help you mark up some log
messages as a critical like containing
password information or other API
information like personally identifiable
information like IP address so we can
warn you that you're doing something
something strange and you need to be
very careful with that and going forward
you have more signals like beyond login
we have more ideas what needs to be
introduced in open standards and what
needs to be standardized and I'm keep
saying standardization so there is a
across language standardization signals
the decision with new ideas and why
standards are important is because we
want every library every application and
every platform to take dependency up on
open sensors and make sure that the
objective ability comes out of the box
is every component and to do that we
need to this library writers to trust us
and make sure that it's it's a true
standard we have another project and C&C
of doing the same thing doing
standardization across distributor agent
it's called open tracing and I'm happy
to tell that we already announced we
merging projects this is a big deal
everybody was asking about difference
between open cells open tracing the
right differences but it's better
together and this merger is not about
one project and is this merger is about
merging community of
same minded people who want to work
together to build standards for
monitoring and to make sure that my
entering you take my entering for
granted when you deploy your application
it's a full merger I mean we'll announce
new name for the project and we'll
announce end-of-life all the libraries
and all those announcements you probably
come when kubernetes could be con
confidence Europe and of may another
announcement we want to make and the
open cells community actually working on
standardization in external bodies like
w3c and next Monday we target declaring
that specification for trace context
going into a candidate recommendation
stage Canada recommendation is a stage
one you can start using this
specification production with that I've
been talking about data collection
standardization on SDKs for a long time
and you're not only making progress on
that front we're also making for a lot
of progress on agent and collector side
and Morgan will talk more about that so
we've started talking the last few
months about some additional components
to open census as I mentioned earlier in
the presentation open census at its core
and certainly from the beginning of the
project is a set of libraries that you
link to your application but we have
more today so starting a few months ago
we began development of the open census
agent this is an application that you
can run on each of your VMs or run as a
daemon set in kubernetes that will
collect traces and metrics from the open
census libraries so your libraries will
export them to the open census agent and
which in turn will then react sport them
to your backend of choice one of the big
big benefits of the open census agent is
that you can choose and change your
exporters to your back-end without
having to redeploy your app this is
particularly big for platforms so
certainly inside of Google for gke if we
wanted to use open census to show traces
and metrics that come from the gke
platform itself this was a requirement
we're not we don't have customers
rebuild kubernetes for themselves but
it's also useful for your own
applications right it's generally pretty
annoying with open census or even open
tracing which which Sergey mentioned
both of them today require you
to recompile rebuild redeploy your app
to change exporters with the agent you
no longer have to the second thing we
have is the open sentence collector this
is based off of the agent it's in some
sense a version of the agent that is
running as a network service typically a
service inside of kubernetes the
collector will work to take in all the
traces and metrics from your application
they'll be sent to the collector and
because they're all sent to that central
source in addition to allowing you to
change your exporters in real time like
you can if the agent the collector will
also allow you to do things like tale
based sampling and so that means instead
of randomly sampling traces you can
choose to just send traces for high
latency requests requests of errors to
your back-end this is a big big deal for
people who do distributed tracing
because it means that what that sampling
that a lot of customers do at 1% is
suddenly much more effective and Steve's
gonna do a demo of that in a few minutes
now cutting to my laptop
we also today are going off a new
feature of the open Santa's agent that
we haven't we haven't presented before
so the open census agent because it's
running on every VM or as the daemon
cetera kubernetes can also collect
system metrics this is something we just
added right before the conference but
it's now there in the source code and
[Music]
and so what we've got here is stack
driver this could be Prometheus this
could be any metrics back-end it would
it would effectively be the same and
we've got the open census agent running
on a number of our VMs for the hipster
shop demo app and we're collecting CPU
time for the system CPU time user CPU
time idle time and information about all
the processes running on those machines
this is coming from the open census
agent it's collected directly from that
from that machine all right from those
machines actually there's multiple this
is a big big vision into where we're
gonna be in a few months at the open
census agent our goal or our plan is to
also have it be a great place to select
all the system metrics that you need
from things like collect these stats D
and so on and so by deploying this open
census agent to each of your VMs by
deploying by pushing out the open census
libraries to each of your applications
you can now get application telemetry
and system telemetry that are correlated
and sent to your back-end of choice this
is pretty easy to deploy I'm not going
to go into depth
but what I can show you here is the
exporter configuration so this is inside
one of the services that already has the
open the open census library link to it
you simply configure the open census
agent exporter pointed at the agent and
then we have a llamo file that deploys
the open census agent as a daemon said
it's really really simple this the
images are already pre-baked so you can
just use them and unlocks a ton of
powerful functionality we haven't had
before we should switch back to the
slides and with that I'm gonna give you
Steve he's gonna give you a great demo
of the open set to Sage and collector
thanks Morgan all right so we talked a
lot about open census there's different
pieces here we have the client libraries
we have the open census service so now I
actually want to demonstrate how you can
leverage this power let's start with the
client libraries
so first let's assume I want to
instrument an application I'm going to
use a java application here and I know
it's early so we'll walk through this
line by line you don't have to try to
figure it out but how would you go ahead
and add instrumentation to your code so
you can take advantage of let's say
distributed tracing in this case so
first you need to instantiate a tracer
basically this allows you to manipulate
and add additional metadata about the
types of interactions between your micro
services or even your function level
calls next you need to export this to a
backends it doesn't matter what back-end
that is here I'm using Zipkin it can be
any exporter destination I'll talk about
the ones that are supported by open
census and a little bit next you
determine your sampling policy by
default open census samples one in
10,000 traces if you want to do
something less aggressive you can do
that in this case for for demo purposes
I'm sampling everything clearly it's
scale that may not make sense but for
the purposes of demonstrations that's
pretty straightforward those three lines
are really the only things that you need
to configure globally for each of your
languages so in the case of Java here I
can go ahead and throw this into my
common library and then reuse it across
my application stack then all I really
need to do is add the instrumentation to
the calls that I'm making between my
services now for demo purposes there is
a sleep in here that's because there's
actually batching being done and if you
don't wait long enough you wouldn't
actually see the traces that's why it's
here but in your application you clearly
wouldn't have that
and then finally here's how you get a
trace right here's the roots pan for
example of a call coming in you can do
the exact same thing to create a child
spanned as well so for each of your
function calls or at least between your
micro-services calls you can go ahead
and add instrumentation and that can
help you stitch together a trace it's
really that easy
all right there's not much to it in
addition you can enhance these logs or
enhance these traces with additional
pieces of metadata like logs so if you
wanted to for example if there was an
error stack maybe of a Java stack trace
that you want to include you can embed
that into the span when you're creating
the span you can say if there's an error
go ahead and tack on that that log
message as well you can also add rich
metadata like key value pairs so you
could add things like what region is
this service deployed in what version of
the code is it running and you can use
this metadata to actually get some rich
insights out of the data and I'll show
that in a second so that's it from a
client library perspective clearly would
be different if you using go or note or
what have you but there's good
documentation we have on open census
that IO to help get you started if you
already have your own instrumentation
that's fine as well because the open
census service actually supports a wide
variety of formats today so as Morgan
was talking about the open census
service is really made up of two
different components the OSI agents and
the OSI collector and you can choose to
use one either both or neither it's
really up to you it comes down to your
business requirements so here I can I'm
showing kind of some different
topologies of how you might deploy this
the OSI agent can actually did we
deployed with your application as a
binary it can be ployed as a sidecar if
you're using docker it can be deploy as
a daemon set if you're in the kubernetes
worlds the collector is a standalone
application and can handle aggregation
of this data as well and of course you
have the OSI client library which you
can use as well now it doesn't matter
how you mix and mingle this like for
example as Morgan was talking about you
have different backends here I have
Zipkin Prometheus and emission alright
well maybe I don't want to use Zipkin
anymore I want to switch over to Jager
it's just a configuration change
everything else handles is handled
automatically maybe I don't want to use
the OSI library because I already have
instrumented in Jager no problem Jager
can is accepted by the agent and the
collector as well let's say that I don't
want to use
and I just want to send directly to the
collector that's fine I don't want to
use the collector I only want to send to
the agent that's fine
but at the end of the day we would
recommend you leveraging all the
different components because they
provide different value ads but you can
choose to peach that piece this together
however makes sense for your environment
now some of the values provided here
with the open census service you now
only have to support a single exporter
destination so for example if I'm using
the OC client libraries I can export and
just go and I'm all set I don't have to
worry about writing that in Java and
note in different languages that makes
it much easier one thing to maintain one
exporter that's really nice
in addition I can change my back-end
whenever I want
after I've instrumented and I've sent to
the open Census Service it's a
configuration change to send my data to
a different location whether I want to
replicate it so I send the two different
backends or I want to switch back ends
all that translation is handled
automatically for you in the open census
service and then the collector actually
offers some advanced functionality for
example intelligent or tail based
sampling the only open source solution
today that actually has that built-in
redaction supports you can actually
strip away tags if for whatever reason
there's information there that you don't
want to be sharing you can tack on
additional metadata like region
information maybe you don't want to add
that into your application itself you
could actually do it from the collector
and actually say all spans that are
being received from this collector
should have this region tagged so
there's a lot of flexibility here
depending on the requirements that
you're trying to meet and really the
open census service is about universal
support so here are just a few of the
different types of receivers and
exporters that are supported today a
wide range and this open census service
is extremely flexible you can actually
add more and more being added all the
time so it doesn't matter whether you
don't see your logo up here it can be
added and you'll be able to transform
into and out of these different formats
so receivers are how you get data into
the system so either into the agent or
into the collector exporters or how you
get data out of the system so all this
translation is handled for you
automatically
making it a truly vendor agnostic
solution now one thing you might be
thinking about is ok let's say I'm using
the collector what about scale does this
thing actually scale the answer is yes
we actually have performance numbers on
the open
census service github page that you can
take a look at but as an example we have
been testing it at significant scale for
example seventeen point three billion
spans a second that's equivalent to
about two hundred thousand seventeen
point three billion spins a day my bad
which is equivalent to about two hundred
thousand spans a seconds that roughly
accumulates to fifty seven terabytes of
data
these were three point three kilobyte
spans span sizes can vary anywhere from
like say one to two hundred bytes up to
maybe ten eleven kilobytes depending on
the number of tags or the rich metadata
that you've added there with no drops
and this was on a single collector so
typically we're seeing about ten
thousand spans per second for one point
two cores of compute and this does scale
linearly so you can make it as small or
as large as you want another reason why
you might consider the collector I
talked a little bit about intelligence
sampling and Morgan mentioned it as well
so there's a notorious problem if you
will with tracing and that is it's
extremely verbose this is very similar
to logging but there's no verbosity
level in tracing so you have a couple of
options on how to deal with this you can
either try to collect all of it at scale
that can be very hard head based
sampling it's very common basically when
you're about to create the initial route
span you make a sampling decision on
whether or not you want to actually
sample that request or nots
the problem with head based sampling is
that you don't actually know what's
going to happen downstream you're making
the decision at the entry point so for
example maybe the route span is fine but
there was an error down the stack you
won't know if you didn't actually sample
that Trace tail based sampling takes the
opposite approach it basically says let
me collect the entire trace and then
make a sampling decision so you can
actually do some pretty cool things you
can say I only want to sample error
traces if any of the spans contain an
error let's sample that you can do
tagged base so you can look for certain
metadata in these spans or in these
traces and then make a sampling decision
based on that or my personal favorite
you can do something like retrieval
based so you can actually say let's make
a sampling decision let's assume that a
trace was not sampled and then your back
end can say hey actually I do need that
trace do you still have it and it can
actually ask the collector for it and
pull it out and actually make
that it does get ingested or ensure that
it's ingested going forward we actually
have a demo of this so you can go ahead
and take a look at it's all available on
the github page so it's actually a
docker compose and I want to walk
through that real quick with a demo
which I hope will show up well on the
screen here let's take a did we switch
its some part of the slide that ki could
we switch back perfect and let's try
alright actually looks pretty good on a
big screen I like this so here is the
tale based sampling demo basically it's
a docker compose file it's made up of a
configuration file to deploy the docker
containers here there are going to be
two different Jager instances and then
it has the configuration for the open
census service so we're basically
configuring two different destinations
one to receive only error traces and the
other to receive both error and non
error traces so we can go ahead and fire
this up you can run this locally on your
system you can deploy this into your
public cloud of choice it doesn't matter
it will spin up a Cassandra instance
with different key spaces for the two
Jaeger instances it'll fire up Jaeger
and then in the open census world we use
this hipster demo shop and there's
actually a load generator utility that
will go ahead and send in traces from
the hipster demo shop and send that into
the open census service which will then
handle the splitting of the traffic for
you automatically it takes a few seconds
to get spun up here and then you can go
ahead and navigate to 17,000 an 18,000
that's the two different Jager instances
so the first one receives all of the
traces all the spans that are being
received so here we can take a look at
that cart service and you can see that
there are spans coming in but there are
no errors up there and if we look at
18,000 and again we go look at the cart
service you'll see that we only see
error traces that's because we have tale
based sampling enabled and we basically
said we want only traces that contain
errors to go to one destination we want
everything to go to the other it's very
simple very easy to configure with a
yamo based configuration all right one
more quick demo so let's tie this all
together we have our client libraries
pretty easy to get instrumented and
started or if you already have your
existing instrumentation you can
leverage that we
talked about the open census service and
how it's easy to kind of get data in and
change it into different formats so you
can switch different backends or take
advantage of it more advanced
functionality such as tale based
sampling but what is really the power of
the data that you get on the other end
now open census is more than just
distributed tracing it's also metrics
it's also logs but I'm going to show an
example with distributed tracing because
that's very powerful in the cloud native
world with microservice based
architectures it's really critical to
kind of understand how your system is
behaving and so just looking at
individual symptoms is typically not
sufficient you want context in
correlation and that's what distributed
tracing can provide for you so we've
talked a little bit about the hipster
demo app if you haven't seen it before
here's kind of a visual representation
of it every rectangle here represents a
different service it's actually a
polyglot architecture so every one of
these boxes is written in a different
language this is available on github so
you can actually take it for a spin and
try it out and basically we want to
demonstrate what a request flow through
this system might look like so if you've
ever used a distributed tracing tool
let's say Zipkin or Jager then you may
be familiar with something similar to
this it's just an actual trace so you
can actually see the different call
through a single request here here you
can see coming into the front end
hitting the checkout service payment
service a few other services so now I
know the calls that were made for a
certain request into my system I also
get some information about the duration
of how long those different operations
took that can be useful from a
performance standpoint and for each of
these as they're known as spans you
actually have rich metadata so you can
drill into it and you can get
information about what that call did so
in the case of like RPC or rest calls
you might be get get the status code I
talked about tacking on metadata to the
collector so here for example you can
see region information maybe you have
billed information about your version
that you can tack on as well you can
kind of control how much rich
information you want to include in these
spans but you can also do some more
interesting things would distribute
tracing and for that I want to show one
more demo
all right so let's start here I'll pause
it first so here is the hipster demo app
again this is built purely from
distributed traces so if you're in
receiving traces from Zipkin or Jaeger
or the open census client library just
distribute tracing information you can
go ahead and construct the hipster demo
shop and this is what it would look like
visually and you can see the different
calls that are happening and if there
are errors or problems with them they
kind of clearly stand out you can also
get information about the backend
database is there any other platform
services that you're leveraging now for
this particular example let's assume
that you're hearing that the
recommendation service and production is
having problems and you're being asked
to go ahead and investigate it so let's
go ahead and do that using only
distributed tracing information so I can
go ahead and actually click on the
recommendations service and I can get
some rich information about the requests
that are being made here I see a lot of
red that's probably bad but there's high
cardinality in my data let me go ahead
and break it down by the different
environments I have well now I can see
that yes only production has errors
stagg and development is fine I can see
that for my different regions they're
both receiving errors so that doesn't
give me much information but I can also
see that a certain build number build
2:35 that is the one that is
experiencing issues so very quickly I
can go and say I have a bad build here I
need to go roll that back it's impacting
my environment that's all with just
distributed tracing data not with
metrics not with logs that provides some
rich correlation in contacts and a rich
way to actually divide my data up and I
can actually take this distribute
tracing information and let's stay with
the logging spec that Sergey was talking
about you can tack on information like
the trace ID and the span ID and now I
can actually say for given trace show me
all the logs for that request or from a
given log go ahead and show me the
topology of how that actually looks from
a call perspective in my environment or
my application it's very powerful and
all this is enabled through open census
all right so call to action no
presentation would be complete without
one
please join us there's a lot to do in
the open census community there are
plenty of client libraries that we would
love your help on the open census
service we have several github issues
open they're usually pretty well labeled
with Help Wanted or good first issue if
you're interested in contributing back
please go ahead and join us on Gator we
have a gator community where we actually
talk about open census publicly and if
you're interested in trying more of the
intelligence sampling that's available
as well all that is on github and with
that I'll turn it back over to Morgan
fantastic
so obviously open census is an open
source project it's a big one as some
heavy hitters in it Google created the
project we're one of the biggest
contributors Microsoft's a huge
contributor as his on mission a big big
growing community I'd be remiss to
forget about post mates they developed
the entire Erlang library they make a
ton of other big contributions and
there's a ton of other smaller
contributors I sort of when I was making
the sliders a little worried like I
don't want to leave out any of the
smaller contributions from other groups
these are just the sort of the
organizations that have committed the
most code we obviously have a lot of
support for exporters and backends that
you can send data to with open census
most of those are maintained by their
respective bodies dated I contributed an
exporter for data dog
I think honeycomb built their own and so
on some of them were built by the open
sentence community but it's a you know a
big big diverse ecosystem what we're
excited about today is announcing that
another big company is promised to make
large contributions to the project and
so joining our us at this conference and
and joining the open census project is
dynaTrace one of the world's biggest I
think the world's biggest APM vendor and
to talk about that we have a Louise
Wright power yeah hello
i'm alois right power from dynaTrace I'm
leaving out that's not just like this
but it's yeah it looks good though I'm
leaving open source initiatives here at
dynaTrace and yeah we I think we had our
first conversation about a year ago and
interestingly very much from the
beginning I think we have were on the
same and had the same ideas and how we
should evolve we should really all
collaborate around collecting trace data
and that we all have like our own
backends that provide our own benefits
to our customers and also for us it
diners ways where a couple years back we
started to focus more on AI and
analytics obviously having the data
input data and we want to give all our
customers also the flexibility to
augment your data with what you can get
by our open sensors and I can next slide
thank you so this is actually a preview
that I have taken directly out of our
development process here what you can
see here is actually dynaTrace actually
open census data in dynaTrace so we're
now on weekly calls was the open census
team ortho respectively Google and
Microsoft here where our focus is really
we provide open census data as
first-class citizen within dynaTrace and
also also providing our input especially
around height span builders to higher
level api's for open census
[Music]
you